it takes a village to create success in
my eyes and as long as you have people
that believe in you you can there's no
there's nothing that you can't get
except for success if you're not having
fun doing it you're not gonna be able to
keep doing it especially early on that's
plenty holidays my mom would always say
to my baby and it means try your best so
that's kind of a on record in my mind so
success for us means that there is a
trusted and reliable solution out there
that everyone knows about I think it's
one of the most important ingredients is
or startup success it really should just
be relaxed right and really to just
never give up and to see as failure as a
way to get closer to succeed building a
brand that many people have heard about
because they've used the product and I
just helped them take back some of their
time is this a belief in myself and
having a faith that a hard work that I
put into my craft will show itself
results will follow